do we will leave these experiments alone
for a bit
so there's several things I want to do
with
this first thing
the
first thing I want to figure out is how
we get rid of this
layer
overall hey
Spencer what do you want me to say
working hyper prints as
IPR well I'm curious with a few things
uh are do the same parameters work for
continuous and discrete or are they very
yeah I don't know if we have support for
that at the moment for having multiple
sets of
pamps definitely keep them
saved but I'm going to have to figure
out how we integrate that
stuff what I'm planning on doing today
is I'm just going to see if I can get us
a nice cleaned up stable Dev Branch with
all the new things that we're testing
working so we can just run all the
experiments we
caffeine I do my hard interval session
on
Tuesday takes a lot out of me
small thing to add to set up make you
work in
Dev yeah just make a separate PR
I can merge stuff whenever today so just
let me
know also I'll show you so these ones
didn't finish yet but uh these oblations
here
so this is without
G we have what looks like about 60
mil 60 mil to solve 60 mil steps and I
believe it
was burito
front 220 seconds so a little under 4
minutes and there is uh there's a piece
of code that needs to be optimized it's
slowing it down so it should be you know
a close to 3 minute
solve fast to solve with
j i I think this is faster than
GAE I mean we need to like rerun full
sweeps but Spencer apparently found a
faster one on continuous breakout so I
don't know how that we're going to
factor that
in uh let me
see I believe it's the 87 this
one yeah so this is the best sweep I
believe that we have
seconds and mind you there's still some
stuff to improve just like
implementation speed of one of the uh
the processing steps for the new one
what I'm doing here today is I'm just
trying to get a nice clean way to test
all the different things we're working
place oh nope I need the uh I need it up
top
okay
it 3B mean e3b STD
this
uh it doesn't look like you're applying
this here at all
should probably not call it gamma we're
going to get it confused
let's do it the other way around
actually we'll
[Music]
Times there we
go
good oh it's the other way around isn't
it
because you don't yeah if you don't Norm
it at all you just get the
there's the
norm
R
junk and that is a much
cleaner feature set
right much
cleaner and we still have to do sampling
though
oops for
actions what I think I'm going to do is
I'm going to take all this stuff
going today we are going to clean up the
dev Branch we're going get some cool
experiments
going there's the
on perfect
then this has got to be like
policy continuous or
something that'll give us
actions log prob we not care about
entropy in here I guess we don't
now I guess before we proceed I try to
get this thing to
policy lstm
see
it's funny when I have uh refactor days
like this
it's not too many people want to watch
me just refactor stuff all day but this
is how I get everything
done like honestly this is probably one
of my more valuable
skills certainly one that's taking the
longest to get good
at
yeah action and
issue yeah what we're doing Captain we
have the thing is that this this is
actually kind of tricky this is not
going to be permanent but I want to uh
going forward I want to remove the clean
RL wrapper from puffer because you know
we have our own stuff now so we'll wrap
it for use with clean RL rather than
making our thing use the clean RL
wrapper we need support for uh e3b
temporarily until we decide whether it's
any good p3o which is the new algorithm
until we decide whether it's you know
consistently better than po
um sweeps the new sweeps API and a few
other things
lots of good
changes man there's like there's some
really state-ofthe-art stuff in here the
thing is ultimately we're not going
to what other contributors puffer lib
this is mostly my own code
uh want is your V more valuable because
otherwise if you just look at the
majority of research code you'll get it
like the majority of research code is
unusable like the vast majority of
research projects they just failed
because they collaps under the weight of
people not being able to write
reasonable code and uh Captain the goal
here is we're not actually going to tack
on all these features permanently to
puer lib either that's not how I build
stuff we're going to tack these on on in
Dev for long enough for us to you know
consistently and accurately confirm that
this is BET like the this is better than
the previous thing and then we're only
going to keep the best code path so if
e3b is no good we just delete it if P30
is good we delete J and we don't keep
know all the options
I think this is going to be the way that
we get up we just make sure everything
stays simple and
Compact and then I think that we're
going to be maybe in a month maybe two
tops we're going to be ready to ship a
puffer lib
2.5 I think the two major contributions
right one major out contribution to
PO um major hyper parameter sweep
contribution clean in refactored M code
and a few new Ms Right
Spencer's uh Tower climb your impulse
Wars bet made a little one as
well a few new
M's you're going to have new features
out of the box better training stronger
baselines and I think we'll be in a good
spot
to ship like a
2.5 I don't understand why 2.0 was
instead of 1.1
marketing so here's the thing the big
lab started doing stupid [ __ ]
versioning going like three
3.54 so now if you release your
versioning is 1.1 nobody cares because
it's a minor update
that's literally
it what sounds better you know we
release puffer lib 0.8 ddev or we
release puffer lib
2 watch eventually they're going to be
jumping like they're going to just like
one up each other on versioning until
they come full circle
that's so stupid but I get it
right this is the current the current
result of all the
promotion this doesn't just happen on
its own
well we're going to have to catch up to
open AI inversion and then the goal is
you get ahead of the big labs in
versioning right oh yeah we're shipping
fast at them we're on five though and
they're on
well the thing is like they they run out
of numbers like so then they go to other
stuff so they do 40 instead of like 4.0
so then what we're going to just do is
we're just going to start picking
species of puffer fish
uh here this is yeah the next release
will just be
maboo puffer lib
Edition the funny thing about that is
it's the stupidest possible versioning
because you can't even tell by looking
at it which one's the most recent
you can't tell which is the most recent
right like Google does this with their
tpus I think that they had like they had
puffer fish and then they have like a
viper fish and like I don't know they
named their tpus after fish
Mao fun
fact I think there's a
247 if this thing still
works damn
it
a they took this down there used to be a
247 mu puffer
camera
awkward all right of policy
and because this changes every single
model it's
irritating not a good way of doing
what was the standard deviation on the
value function
guy Costa is the goat if you don't
follow Costa on X and you are on X like
you really should he's honestly the goat
like I think I'm going for the title of
RL Exorcist or RL Paladin or something
cool like that because goat's already
taken Costa's got
it
Costa he has a very silly handle even
sillier than mine
if you don't know Costa like he is
awesome so you can just look up Costa
hang uh he's at Allen now he built clean
RL RL is screwed without clean RL like
he built the only good simple RL Library
when there were
none um yeah he's pretty awesome puffer
lib is built on cleanar and yeah we've
done a lot since then but you know we
really have built off of his train
scripts quite a bit
he's now doing RL on language models so
luckily I don't have
to because I do not like working on
language models it is no
fun I like the things that I do
now critic is standard deviation
one
yeah Costa is like one of the only
people I know that can also have a
pretty Balanced Life and still be
incredibly productive I kind of have to
be all in on stuff to get anything
yeah I mean I don't even I don't work as
crazy hours as I used to either I mean I
still put in good hours I don't put in
as crazy hours but um
a lot of the hours that I'm missing now
I put into you know taking way better
care of my not mental health my physical
health right just like actually getting
in like getting and staying in good
shape uh and that has paid dividends
because I would have literally died of
pneumonia two months ago had I not been
in such good shape so [ __ ] happens it
pays to be it pay is to prioritize your
health you know when I got Co that did
nothing to me at all
like you know no
damage had it like two or three times no
damage at
all become a lot more resilient to [ __ ]
that goes wrong it's really worth
it it sucks because it takes hours out
of the day you know you go for even if
you just go for like a hard run for like
half an hour you're going to be tired
for the next couple hours and not really
be able to get back to work properly but
it's still worth it
go do you need to pass this
here uh I don't think you need to pass
this here at all actually
right yeah you don't need this at all
you just do
this
have you seen Claude AI play as
Pokemon we absolutely smoke that thing
with 5 million
parameters so they have tens of billions
of dollars and hundreds of billions of
parameters most likely we have a few
garage desktops and some
hobbyists uh and 5 million parameters
and we absolutely smoke
Moon Yeah puffer stock to the
Moon make sure you get your puffer stock
it's funny because you can't buy puffer
stock you can hire us to make all your
rlg go bar and actually work properly
you cannot get any puffer stock though
if you haven't seen the stuff in the
Pokemon Channel you should check it out
um we have yeah we have way better
results on that same
task and actually uh what the developer
of that says that he thinks that they're
using our code as
well imagine contrib to puffer Li is
like buying puffer stock early yeah
pretty much um I mean we will be pulling
people from there for stuff when we
eventually expand though uh yeah I mean
that's one way to get involved or if
you're at a company you know you get
puffer lib uh you get puffer Li for your
stuff we do premium for
that but definitely like if you see the
amount that we do with uh existing open
source contributors like I could review
every single environment every line of
every environment that's submitted you
know I brief people up on new research
um I you know the people that actually
put time into contributing I put time
into like training on this side of stuff
as well
so there is opportunity everywhere
here because I need more I need more
people helping with this research I'm
only one person and there are only so
many hours in the week to get stuff done
so if use
e3b we do it
else
o we do
this good
I think that's
experience also I don't know why I did
this
I don't need either of these stupid pams
right I can put these on the same
line yeah
it's
hello please say us step by
step I try to comment as I can but
mostly what I'm doing at the moment is
I'm just rapid fire refactoring
stuff this is e3b feature this is P30
feature I kind of had these added
halfhazard so now I'm just adding some
signature oh yeah there we
go e3o gives uh p3o is distributional
you needs mean and log standard
values
and all right so this is all temporary
anyway so this doesn't have to be
amazing we're not going to keep these
options permanently what's going to
eventually happen right is this is P30
this is p p uh if p3o is better than P
we'll just delete the original Po and
we'll keep
p3o that is what is most
likely to happen
here see what what other stuff we
hit I I do exercise after and
start a die
live because of I do exercise after and
I not quite sure what that
up use oh yeah this
parameter get rid of this one I replace
this
be these also have to be put
there we just get values
right I forgot to do this
one exercise AI
project there are a few of
those I know they're like some uh some
like lifting progress trackers they use
AI I don't know if they use like
legitimate AI or like you know stupid AI
but
learn
machine learning and linning
um I mean some of the stuff here is
educational the point of this stream is
really just watch I mean this is like
Cutting Edge RL research uh we've come
up with two major breakthroughs this
month alone so this is mostly like a
watch watch reinforcement learning
Advanced live stream we do some
educational stuff but it's not the
primary objective let's say we do train
new
contributors but the primary thing here
is push field forward and I just stream
all the dep CU it's all open source and
people seem to like
it so why
not it also kind of keeps me a little
bit better focused to be honest like I
don't I'll often just zone out and stuff
I don't zone out as much on stream
Reb
in
invite yeah I mean I'm doing different
stuff on different days as well like
today is going to be a heavy refactor
day cuz I want to have this de Branch
nice and clean for everybody who's
currently playing with stuff on like the
new versions of puffer lib um that's a
couple clients that's like you know
contributors it's a bunch of people and
uh we have a whole bunch of experiments
like I think we have between 5 and
10,000 experiments to run over the next
several weeks so that's what we're going
to
do and
Linux if you want to learn Linux you
just download Linux and you start using
it
there's really not that much to
uh I mean there's not that much at least
to be reasonably
oh yeah the other thing I don't know if
Captain is still around today but there
was one nice Hardware release today I
pre-ordered one of these I think this is
probably going to be the best uh the
best work laptop for ML
stuff
overall and they are pricey but I don't
think there's anything cheaper with
remotely close to the same
specs was it yeah 20 800 to start I
think mine was 3500 cuz generally you do
what is
it yeah this config 480 with this a 5080
with this I
mean so I'm looking forward to that they
won't ship for a while
but that'll be fun when that gets
here not so much in Florida because it's
like humid but when I go back to
California and stuff for the summer it's
going to be nice to be able to just
bring laptop upstairs and do uh some Dev
outside very bad luck with multiple
razor yeah their QC is terrible I had to
replace the uh the battery on my my last
one uh cuz it pillowed out but I mean
there really isn't a better you can't
buy anything else that's better there
just aren't very good options for GPU
laptop
like if you want something that has a
reasonable profile has like a metal
build frame um and good specs like there
aren't other options there just
aren't as far as I've
seen I know I like all my Razor gear cuz
it's like yeah the QC is spotty but like
when this stuff works it's very nice
like I got the keyboard here I got my
cameras from them I got the headset I
got the mouse mat I got the mouse pad I
got the bungee I got all sorts of Razor
stuff oh and the mic as well so pretty
much all the peripherals are razor heck
I even got the crazy overpriced monitor
at one point and it was nice um you know
you can do just as well for cheaper with
that one but the other one
generally are pretty darn good for what
they are Razer used to be like the super
overpriced company but now it's like
it's actually very
competitive because everybody else
raised their prices and kept offering
garbage
so that's good
oh wait hold
on yeah this is the
numpy right pretty
well let
yeah no it totally
will yeah like there it's totally the QC
is a problem I bought like probably four
keyboards and like six or seven mice at
this point
um
but they're very very nice when they
work like I really like my uh my
peripherals from them and the thing is
they keep actually making them better
like there are not many companies where
like you actually notice the products
getting better from generation to
generation let me just show you my
keyboard on this so they went
to I can't tell if this is metal or just
like really high density
plastic but it feels
good it's got like the it's like it
feels really good and solid they added
like a little a couple controls at the
top on like a a mid layout keyboard
they've got this wrist rest which they
actually improved because it would it
would degrade over over time they redid
the material on it so it's way more
durable like you can actually see
generation to generation like when you
buy the new one you actually do get a a
noticeable upgrade most of the
time so I really like them for
that you know most like most companies
you buy the next one and it's the same
[ __ ] that they've just like you know up
the price a little bit
that fancy split
keyboard I don't
really I don't know if I could use a
split keyboard maybe it would get me to
type properly so because of programming
um I almost always
I think your pinky is supposed to sit on
semicolon
right I always have my hand shifted like
one position to the left and that's just
how I type like instead of having my
pinky on a it's pretty much always on
shift yeah I have like my whole hands
are just shifted one over to the left so
I think that might screw me
kind of forc got bad ton night yeah yeah
it's no
fun exercise helps a lot
yeah it's pretty hard to get wrist pains
and stuff when you're like lifting a
bunch of
weights I mean I have abs absolutely God
awful genetics for that as well like you
can just see like I'm pretty damn well
in shape but nothing goes on my wrist
right my forearms are way thicker than
my
wrist um or like the top top part of
them way way
thicker it was more so before I lost all
the weight
ponia but yeah it's uh and I I still
have I've never had any like tendonitis
RSI even when I'm like in 14 hours a day
or
anything that's generally the one thing
I actually will promote outside of AI
because a lot of AI people just it's too
much death time you got to you got to be
in shape help everything else
no no no no it's very genetic based so
some people they have long muscle insert
shts and a shorter forearms and if you
have that then you get like you actually
get muscle around your wrists so you get
way thicker wrists so it's like way more
stable and then you can you know you can
bench without wraps you know uh it's
it's useful for a lot of
this is kind of the resolution that I
have to be programming at to have enough
space yeah this is too
big I can't see enough of it if I do
this
um let me check the YouTube stream I
think the resolution on the YouTube
stream should be good at
Max oops
I'm streaming at I think
6K or may yeah let me make sure YouTube
didn't do something
silly let me check the YouTube stream I
think the resolution on the it's fine at
1080p should be good at
Max I can't really make the code bigger
than this on this monitor or like it
starts to get in the way I can't see
enough of it
if quality is bad on YouTube try
twitch but I think they should both be
fine
uh now I have to put the advantage code
back
right yeah so
did you study probability and statistics
my probability and stats knowledge is a
trous my math in general is not great
but problemin stats in particular is by
far my worst um I mean obviously I did
my undergrad I did my standard uh
Stanford undergrad core which has some
probability I did a fair bit of linear
algebra um but honestly my playbook is
85% engineering like 10% basic science
and uh I don't know 5% like actual math
this week has been math heavy because
I've been doing algorithm Dev so like
you know I've done some stuff with uh
what was it I did had to do some
distributional stuff with like gaussia
negative log likelihood uh instead of
square distance error I had to
do I was looking at like expected
Improvement to stuff
for uh for Advantage functions and I to
do a few similar things from Bas and
optimization for parameter
tuning but the majority of my playbook
is
engineering if you're a math heavy
person you can absolutely do good work
being math heavy but for me the
engineering has always been more helpful
what is your idea for GP what is your
idea for
GP do you mean which one do I like more
and they're going to be very close to
comparable
models like they're they're going to
Leap Frog each other back and forth for
the next next few
months I cancelled I canceled Claude and
um chat GPT because grock I think is now
just going to be on par or whatever it's
got really fast generation and I'm good
with that and I you know I have Twitter
premium already so it's perfectly good
for me also by the way if anybody wants
to join the Discord you can be member
1,000 I see we're at $9.99 right
now hey welcome
we're doing lots of De today lots of
refactors thousand people very
solid okay we need this for Advantage
fun I really just want Tesla to ship the
damn $30,000 cyber cab already that
would be
ideal nobody ever has to drive again
perfect
they're probably going to take way
longer than they think to do it
unfortunately don't want to drive at all
nah me mobile yeah
hope in future science makes a new wayi
AI is going to continue for a long time
progress is going to keep on going
no attribute B offs
okay I got to go find the original code
on
this and uh this is adding a lot of
complexity to the puffer script the
clean puffer script but this is not
permanent this is going to occur for as
long as it takes us to run all the
experiments to test all these things
against each other and then we're going
to delete the
underperformers so whatever ends up
being the best gets
kept we're not going to offer all of
these features at the same time it just
crowds out our script for no
reason the focus on puffer is not going
to be supporting everything it's going
to be having the best
thing what does p forli do ultra high
performance reinforcement
learning the a of the stream is you just
watch live Dev on reinforcement learning
live Dev live
research so all of these are ultra high
performance rlms this is an RL agent
playing this in your browser little tiny
neurl net just running it in your
browser playing the
game everything from breakout to like
massively multi-agent
snake these guys will run around you'll
see they'll get larger
and then more complex stuff like this
miniature
MMO which is quite
large you can watch all the different
agents running around and playing the
game what puffer Li
manages put this here
okay this is pretty well set here's a
restroom real quick I'll be back in a
second and uh then we'll get this thing
working be right
is this how I had values done before I
don't think so
code don't just type stuff into GPT and
ask it to write all your code for you
you will not get anywhere doing that
quick proper
Discord
probably but we'll count for
now oh it doesn't refresh though I have
to wait for it to
not really sure what you're saying there
to be
honest as you can see I'm working on AI
and I'm typing all of my
code the one thing I do suggest people
use is single line code complete it just
makes you type
faster which is very
I think I just need to flatten that
right
B let me
see as
[ __ ]
bandages on
on
what the hell did I do with the original
version of
go and
then this goes up
top
turns num
Pi it's going to
this I can just do like this
actually there nump
hang on how's this work self values
nump
advantages comes in sorted but then how
does values on bup get
good uh what did we do
here oh yeah roll out we're not yeah
we're not dealing with roll
missing be
rewards I forget this
it turns what we have
Advantage
value yeah there we
go State okay now I have to do I do have
to update the policy a little
bit so hopefully we don't need too too
much of this
state data. policy. code
observations gives us
OBS lstm State and action action
uh we still need this lstm state before
we detach
it
logits we do not need the Logics
here that seems weird
we should need the
logits yeah we should definitely need
the
Logics okay get the value like
this value
mean value log standard deviation
need a.
policy ah and you need this as
I don't know what's wrong with me that I
like this
more I should just leave the parentheses
there you
better okay you
p3l this information and otherwis we get
that information
good
actions new log
probs and I think that's all
something about like
this that's not
get rid of this
ar oh and we get rid of this AR
perfect I think it's acceptable to do
something like that
and now here we just paste the
original value loss code that we
replaced for no
reason it's perfect there's the original
value loss code
right and
this one goes
entropy should have got an entropy
somewhere
right actions this is
values
mean yeah so
and this
runs cool this actually does
trains now we just have to test all the
uh all the permutations of this clean it
up a
bit we'll do the hyper parameters we've
integration as well and uh I mean for
reference here look this
is not even 400 lines I guess you can
add like an extra 100 from The
Experience buffer down here so let's say
500 lines for all these different
features and the thing is I still don't
even think it's worth having the extra
lines for all these
things I still think it's going to be
better to like you know once we decide
P30 is better we do this we just like
get rid of the other option and we do
that
everywhere it makes the implementation
easier for everyone to follow
project right
here ultra high performance
reinforcement learning uh environments
trainable at up to a million steps per
per second about 100 times faster than
anywhere else and watchable and playable
in
browser this is me playing it but I can
also let the agent take over and the
agent is very
good same for all these
up okay
solid very
solid now this is 145k with
32%
overhead and the other one
60 yeah I think that these two are going
to be roughly the same speed I would be
very surprised if there's a substantial
performance penalty with
P30 it should be quite
fast very
nice now this works
and presumably these are did you put
these on everything or did you just put
this on
Mac yeah but where did you put
it wait hang on where is
this setup.py extra link
ARS in an if condition for Mac okay
that's correct I just wanted to make
sure you did that otherwise it wouldn't
do
anything a look at that 12 successful
checks very good good job thank you very
much
useful little
PR we're almost uh we almost have the
dev repo in a respectable State as well
this is pretty quick progress
AI the only thing that I use which I do
suggest that you use look you see how I
get these suggestions I get like really
obvious single line
suggestions so you do all the thinking
but uh the AI helps you type that I
suggest I mean I can still code
perfectly well without it it's just
annoying because I have to type
everything manually right so it slows
down my typing speed maybe a factor two
or
I have my exact uh development
environment config posted as well uh my
exact like the exact configuration that
I use for my work is available in our
our development container which is on
the
website so it literally takes I mean
plus the download time right but it
literally takes 5 minutes to just get
this exact same development environment
that I have with all the stuff set up
assert probability tensor contains okay
so this thing has exploded
somehow lovely
yeah so this thing is completely
exploded how's that
possible I don't think I reset this
thing ever right
hang
on I thought that i' done uh i' done
resets
this do
it oh still explodes
why does this explode all of a sudden
why does this
explode could just be the coefficient to
be fair
though suon is
definitely screwy here
reasonable let me see what else I had in
the original
one
ah I see
see why this goes to n get up his best s
for learning if you're interested in RL
stuff I have a quick start guide I wrote
this specifically for people trying to
get into the space it's a much more
accessible guide than most of the stuff
out there in RL as well doesn't ask you
to do too much either it's just you know
a pretty small set of papers and some
some insights it's on the blog puff.
it's also on my
ex pretty quick read as well there are
also some nice
videos where is it I highly recommend
the the iceberg video that I did as
well I should have that on the website
but on the YouTube there's an RL Iceberg
video which I highly
recommend I put work into
somehow
e3b e3b is this kind of janky
exploration
algorithm this one
here uh this is supposed to be a
generalization of count space
exploration to continuous space
I don't particularly like it but uh you
know we've had a request to add this so
we're going to at least try it out and
see if we can get it to do
anything I generally think this whole
branch of exploration uh research is not
particularly
promising at least the way it's being
done now but and also the thing that
really annoys me is that this thing
substantially slows down your whole
training which is just not worth it but
you know whatever we'll do
oh it's just cuz they all start in the
same state isn't
will you add grpo or is it already in
the library now grpo is actually pretty
much useless for General RL uh it's just
a language model training algorithm as
far as I can see so we don't really do
that um our focus is mainly on all of RL
outside of language modeling
so there's not really any plan to do
that at the moment unless there's a use
case within the rest of ourl or unless
we have a client that really wants it
for some
reason puffer lib is not really like
it's not a library of implementations in
the same way a lot of other RL libraries
are puffer Li is very simple very high
performance RL and we maintain like the
algorithm that we currently have found
to be the best so we're not trying to
like build a whole bunch of different
tools for people to figure out what's
the best we ourselves figure out what is
the best and provide the best simplest
fastest implementation of
that which right now is PO with a couple
of tweaks and we have some new research
on some better
stuff but poo kind of just shreds
everything when you run it really fast
so okay that's
e3b that seems to
uh so just for fun here
what if we put e3b and P30 on these
maybe these fight each other maybe they
don't guess it just
works yeah so you can use P30 with
e3b p3o is the the new algorithm that we
are
developing
cool I'm going to go grab myself a drink
real quick take a minute and then uh
we're going to continue we have to
implement uh I think there's some hyper
parameter sweep stuff that needs
bindings and needs to be cleaned up so
we'll do that next and then we'll pretty
much have staple Dev Branch probably
only takes me a couple hours and we'll
be done by dinner be right
camera hyper parameter
sweeps clean this stuff up
you think I want to do this
first
so actually I want to commit this first
cuz this was a lot of
this file's too
long demo file keeps getting to be too
damn
I'm going to actually put this in line
because I don't even know if we're
keeping
this just do like this
right
okay this stuff is
commented
so E3 be on its own not super good um
that's normal
though why is this file so
long there's not really that much in it
I guess the config loading takes up yeah
a lot close to half of it CR can get
cleaned up a little bit that but nothing
huge H I guess it's pretty
minimal now the only thing we got to
figure out is carbs
right carbs is a little
awkward we're probably going to want to
test on the original carbs as
well see what we have for
real number
linear okay so we do actually have po 2
in
okay yeah this is fine
um I guess what we're going to have to
do we add this to puffer Li SL
sweeps as a back
end and we just hack around to make it
fit the API for now we really only need
this for running tests
you know this is our
Baseline I think all I need in order to
see that is I look at the demo file from
this says carbs integration right yeah
this
file so we'll just get
sample frequency is
five 10 random suggestions I
believe
o we got some results in that's
nice for
so uh for context here let me hold on
let me answer this message and I'll get
some context on this
okay so context on what I'm doing I
every so often I have to answer like DMS
on support requests and stuff from
collaborators um clients all that stuff
but what we're going to do right now is
we're going to take a look at uh our
hyper Prem sweep algorithm versus imbw
carbs carbs is the Baseline that I built
stuff off it's a very good sweep
algorithm the API is a bit different I
supported it in 20 I don't have support
for it in the latest code so I'm going
to put this back in as a
hack because the next stage of puffer is
going to require
running about 5,000
experiments to give you context for why
um we have about 12 environments at the
moment you need to run usually between
100 and 200 experiments for a sweep on a
single environment so in order to test
one method with a proper sweep on all 12
environments it is 1,200 experiments or
2400 if you're being particularly
pedantic now we have to run these at the
very very least we have to run these for
carbs our new
method um and then
for uh the new algorithm P30 so that's a
minimum of 3,600
experiments if I want to test other
hyperparameter algorithms there are two
more that I have so that could
potentially be another 2400 experiments
and there might still be some more
variations on top of this to test now I
want to avoid running those experiments
until we know that they're ready to go
so realistically what we do is we run
like a few hundred experiments to make
sure that stuff is working first um
which doesn't take that long but uh yeah
that's the plan is we're setting up the
repo to be able to do this and then if
we get the results of those experiments
and they're good we will have soda
hyperparameter tuning for RL with our
new algorithm very simple as well we
will have soda learning algorithm
beating po which I think is likely to
work this is a newer effort uh and then
we also have e3b to test which is explo
probably the soda exploration algorithm
I don't think it's particularly good as
a general purpose Edition to puffer but
we will play with it at the
least that's the one I'm least confident
but three new major additions to
puffer all we have to do is fiddle with
uh this carb stuff as a baseline in
order to get it to
work oh I literally have it down here at
the bottom perfect
I think log linear and logic were the
only ones that originally in carbs
right they had
l in UI
cards we're going to use their
original
spaces so they have
real linear
log logit linear log logic is all they
have so that's we will
use I think you can probably just paste
most of my original code on this
done that's all it is
the way their prams work do you give
them a minute and a Max
you can give them a Min and a Max
right min max
sweep I just modified this thing
actually I wrote this better
function I just have to patch
[Music]
so here's what we had for carbs prams
here's what we have for new prams
oh this is not bad
actually I just need to do
this
car
so these are the actual spaces that we
have
name
space space
search
center
pams you need this or this or
this you just need
these then in puffer carbs
so this is
set and then we have to do
now this just needs
carbs carbs prams I think we still are
going to need observation in
foram so I will uh
I'll keep this
one for in a
second I think we just need these
through
this giv this flat suggestions is the
only Annoying
Thing yeah this gives us flat
suggestions but that's fine for just a
Baseline
suggest yeah
fil so that you give
this
spine and observe
right so I do
hypers hyers score cost is
failure observation in
suggestion yeah that's totally
fine we can leave that for now
okay I think we are pretty well set
to uh to get this going carbs pram
puffer
sweep carbs pram we do not use this one
anymore
here yeah we do not use this anymore so
this is going to be a fair
comparison don't use closest
pal you don't use any of
this so this is now 700 lines that
includes a binding for carbs and all
these comments obviously that's just me
doing experiment so this will get
cleaned up
string too many dimensions
string what
so let's see uh what keyword ARS these
things actually
expect when we do this we
do min
max scale
yeah their scale is going to be
different from my scale so let's remove
that
guess no object
carbs
okay carbs carbs
works okay so this is just going to give
us
cool
so we will
see whether this now does anythings
actually we have lots of runs to look at
now right um so there's this
guy which is
our long running
sweep this is looking very
nice then we've got this one from this
morning which is not quite there
yet and then where's the other one
does I just want to make sure that we
can actually get the uh the suggestions
which it'll take like three runs I
believe or 10 runs however many runs it
takes
just are giving us the carb
suggestions but this is quite
nice and that is pretty much everything
that we needed to
add uh for support at the
moment the clean ourl
scripts I think will need to be
fixed that's no big deal though
I stuff on the
Discord set okay that didn't take as
long as I thought it would I thought
that would take me more time
today I guess then we think about what's
next
there are quite a few things I want to
fiddle with we'll make sure that this
works first and I guess we'll run some
confirmation checks to make sure that we
didn't actually you know that we're
still getting the per that we should be
the next set of experiments we're going
to do
how many experiments do we
have and so it's got to run for a bit
just to make sure that it actually is
doing
something actually you know now is a
good time I will let this run for a few
and I'll be be back when this is done
and uh then we will run some additional
tests to make sure all this is good and
then I will think about the experiments
I'm going to want to set up to really uh
really test all this stuff we'll be
this seems to have run but we not
getting anything learning out of
this oh
no it kind of does something sort
of we will have to double
check possibly just the hyrams are
screwy well
but we know that it runs and the carbs
just not crash which is the important
thing
next thing is going to be making sure we
didn't break anything on our main
runs while I wait for this I'd also like
to look at
the
advantage
oops bandage function here
I'm concerned though that this doesn't
seem to
be yeah this is not as good as before so
I think I broke something
is off P3 of horizon is
correct yeah definitely broke something
oh we're going to have to go look at the
uh go look at the
losses hey there can you recommend a
crash course path for this possible
you're interested in how the IR RL Works
can't figure out how to start yeah I
have a
guide I have a quick start guide that's
much more accessible than most of the
other ones you'll find
you still need some background
but it's on here and it's also on the
X also worth pointing out that
um all but three of these environments
are written by contributors most of whom
came in with no RL experience so getting
involved building environments and you
know contributing stuff to puffer Li is
also a really good way to learn RL
I could review all of them live on
stream
wor something is very screwy with
this don't think what I could have
broken realistically there are a lot of
things they could have broken right for
fine is analyz for
game
uh what I don't know what that means
think what would have been wrong
here like what things did I
change probably just have to go through
the
losses new value mean new value log
standard
deviation be loss right
me I could have screwed up ordering I
guess
right flatin
batch
cuz Okay so this is sorted
yeah these are sorted so this should be
fine but
nothing I don't know what you're saying
man
hey
welcome how's it going in
somniac we're working on clean Dev
Branch with e3b
uh P30 p with
G new sweeps carb sweeps everything all
working so we can use it to run all the
experiments and I have it running but I
think I broke something in the
process I definitely broke something in
the
process I'm just looking for that
got rid of the
hypers well P30 doesn't use
them and uh that's in testing but it
looks like it's very good
so at least look at no
J we'll see from
there okay
so actions
where's
actions be
actions self
actions B idx is
fine
values B flat that's fine
it's got to be something not getting
computed
right I don't know what else it would
actually I'm trying to think what could
possibly have broken
here what could I have even
this minus new log prob minus log prob
no but I have it here this seems
learn that's a good question does po
learn
looks like it
learns so somehow there is a P30
specific
bug if this is
correct let it run a little longer
stuck can get it is these should be
really good hyper
parameters value
actions lock
prob
rewards D and by
fine method equals protein protein is
the name of the new hyper preter sweep
algorithm that I've been
developing because it's based on carves
part is a uh a different algorithm
I'm trying to think what stuff I edited
that could possibly
cause this difference
both so I mean I would think that this
would
be like the data going into training
mismatch between
log you might have just found it let me
see log
somewhere so this is log prob in forward
pass and then I store log
prob right and then here I have the log
props so logor probs and
new log
props that looks
right unless you saw I messed up the
name
somewhere I mean yeah it probably be
new log FRS
similar log I think you have it right
log yeah cuz the new log problem is from
here and then log PRS comes from up here
in the
experience it's for game user there's no
game user here this is all for
algorithm I just don't know what the
heck I could have broken
right it's pretty clear that something
is broken and it's affecting both this
and
po you use the
Logics yeah you use them just right in
the sample
again made PR for breakout presume you
have updated
hypers in one of your
branches well yeah but the thing is
they're different across algorith so
I've been like doing a bunch of stuff
hopefully you didn't just overwrite the
uh the existing ones let me
see log of problems yes log is the prob
log of the action probabilities for each
possible action left it alone
this a flat and continuous should be off
by default I would
hope false yep very
whatever is there before doesn't work
because actions were
changed rerun discreet and
[Music]
upload why would that change the
um why would that change the hyper
parameters
entropy did I miss something
here this is an eval actions log prob
and then I store actions and log prob
right then here in train I have actions
new log
prob
right and here you have to pass the
stored action so you get the log prob
for this specific
action action sampling may be
inconsistent well it's supposed to be
different across these two right this
should be
so in the original code
do policy of
OBS and
state so we pass OBS and
state right and then in
train we we pass OB State and we pass
the action so in the new one we had we
split this up so it's not just one
policy call
make sure the lstm isn't doing something
silly and you're passing hidden in
encode platin obs
for re
decode decoder mean log standard
deviation
has two values action lock blobs rewards
DS trunks
rewards I have reward
block there also a rewards
term let's see for
if I actually want to just go through
the effort of doing a get BCT on
this I always for get the commands for
that cuz I so rarely have
this is just as well can ask if there's
data in
I guess we're going to have to do a
bisect on this
oh hang
on I only have one freaking commit there
damn
it how do I only have one commit I
thought I'd committed uh
and there very damn confused because oh
you know I was just being stupid hold
on J
Dev yeah so I can't have broken anything
here because this is literally just the
hyper primam
stuff so I must have already broken it
which is unfortunate
so bisect is not going to
help and now we have a relatively longer
PR we can deal
puffo scanned this thing several times
though
it so I wouldn't think that would
totally break it but maybe
try
this for
yeah that was it I just screwed up the
lstm state very small screw
up okay so
um now what we do is we
try we try this out we see if we
reproduce curves
yeah so uh I think that this will pretty
much give
us the ideal setup to test everything we
wanted to test over the next several
weeks
so provided that these match The
Originals the quick outline of the plan
going forward we
have the new hyper parameter algorithm
protein we've got P30 which is the
upgraded po
um we have e3b to
test we've got carbs integrated as a
Baseline and we've got a couple other
hyper Prem Suite baselines so what we're
going to want to do here there are a few
modifications I want to test out on
carbs or on uh protein the new sweep
algorithm I need to resolve one Quirk
with the
new uh p3o
algorithm and I probably I'm going to
need to fix a lot of like M specific
things so that we can sweep all the MS
cuz there're a couple little bugs uh
with some of the Ms and sweeps playing
nicely but from there we should be able
to just like run set of 100 experiments
per environment and get some really nice
metrics
back that'll be
nice we're going to see how breakout
does with these
parameters these aren't tuned for
breakout though I
see yeah so this is the chart for this
one oh we also have to do um we have to
see if we can optimize
the uh the C code for the new Advantage
function a little bit as
well we should have time to do that
today
these are not the Super competitive
breakout parameters for this algorithm
mind you these are these were tuned for
e3b
My Hope though is that with the new
algorithm the fact that you no longer
have gamma and
Lambda it's pretty
substantial and then I think that
learning rate I have a plan to you will
stop to have a learning rate but I have
a plan to make it way easier for
tuning that we'll talk about soon and
then entropy is the one I don't know
about I think entropy in
general entropy is a really stupid bonus
term that's currently
used I'd like to replace it with
something better but I just don't know
if there any good General options at the
moment right like what would you replace
entropy
with it's supposed to be exploration
bonus it's a really dumbb exploration
bonus but I don't think there's anything
that's just generally better
I should think about that actually so
entropy is just don't put all your
probability
Mass uh
on one action
right there anything obvious I can do
that's
better no I mean my version of
exploration I do think that there is a
version of exploration research that
makes
sense but it's going to be something
like you know it's going to be something
like an uncert something like
uncertainty minimization I would
think but I the thing is I don't know
how you do uncertainty minimize
ation uh without predicting the next
state
right is there a good way of quantifying
uncertainty
without predicting the next date
on you could say that LE
more less certain State should have
higher action
entropy and use entropy as a reward not
just a loss bonus but I don't think that
that'll necessarily
enough entropy doesn't seem like a good
version of
uncertainty maybe it
is actually maybe that's not
terrible what do we think about that
entropy
loss so as a loss term entropy just says
whatever States you're currently
um try to you know maintain some
probability Mass on all the
actions but as a reward
term it can actually say go to states
that are higher
entropy Maybe maybe that's enough
wouldn't that be so funny if it's just
like you take the existing thing exactly
as it is but you just move it up a
couple lines and it works way
better I'm going to try that
next that's actually potentially a
really promising idea
there's some built-in assumptions there
you know maybe you can do better somehow
but right so 850 so pretty much a solve
not quite a full solve but pretty much a
full solve these aren't optimized
parameters and then we'll do this one
through uh isn't there a P30 coefficient
or no maybe
not and then we'll see the the next
one actually let me I'm going to check
that on see if uh rock is aware of
this
rad off in the loss not a state specific
reward interesting
H I want to try
that that seems uh very promising to
me also we are at 700 reward in sub 50
mil which
is where is
it
yeah pretty good
and
8:30 that's almost
SED in 50
wouldn't that be so funny if I actually
got like quality Exploration with
something that
simple people have been doing all this
exploration research that'd be so
funny the thing is I wouldn't even be
surprised if that
worked so this is right here this is a
solve in 60 mil there's a little bit of
unab instability here but it should go
back up so this is a this is a good
Baseline we are well set with our
baselines here
um I'll use the restro real quick while
this finishes and then we'll figure out
some sweep stuff to set up right
yeah okay so next thing here well first
I actually I want to check on these
solve way more expensive
here can I tell already if these are
going to be really different
[Music]
sweeps I don't know it is a little weird
that this is so far out here oh you know
what no it isn't it's just the the fact
that the script takes a while to run so
let's optimize
all right let's figure out the uh the
timing issue on
this CU this should be a quick thing to
do and uh this should be like a one and
done so the issue here and I think we
get to do some somewhat am using syon
Shenanigans uh we need M Copy
probably okay original hold on original
discrep Pam still train and eal works
seemingly actions all become zero on the
C file
demo uh yeah because it's writing that's
just a data type issue man you need to
just um CU it's going to try to Output
an INT for the action you probably just
need to cast it correctly before you
move it to a float If It Moves Like The
btes of the int into the btes of the
float it's not going to
work inside the actual C next it's
coming from M actions as zero
well the SC that writes to the actions
buffer right
also uh this is not with optimal hyper
parameters for
um for po but this is our tuned P30
run I think they're about the same when
you have them uh both tuned separately
but it's pretty cool because in a sense
this is I mean they should be the same
it's just the uh the hyper prams like
there two extra hyper prams you have to
tune what is that in time uh not a fair
comparison yet because
the uh the C code for the new reward
function is slow I have to make the C
code faster and then it'll be good
yeah but even with that I will say even
with this low C code which is eating
another 10 20% at
least uh The Sweep that we
have we have all these runs at like 224
240 so this is 4
minutes sub four
minutes even with the existing
okay 4.7 that is abysmal it
takes 5 Ms to run this
thing and that's on 32 holy
hell okay
how do you do this though so it
um T greater than num steps minus
one I + J
it holy hell how is there not just like
[ __ ]
know guns of
tea
does this just generate really
bad index code or something
oh or it could be the allocations
actually right
yeah so that's slower so it actually it
should
be we'll see it could be the allocation
doesn't need to be of ID AIS like this
either just a sort
okay quite a bit
actually it's still
slow and you actually have to zero it
right
actually it might be slower when you
zero it come to think of it we'll see
yeah it doesn't look good at
all do
okay do anything I don't think that
should change anything we'll
see doing a copy of stupid
right yeah something's definitely wrong
with these
steps oh
yeah I
see yeah cuz it can only go ahead so
many
steps
two yeah and then for negative one
there's nothing you can do the last
sample has to get masked out
um because there's nothing to
right now the only thing I'm not sure
here uh episode bounds right that's a
problem CU this thing gets sorted
but we don't handle episode bounds I
don't
think so yeah that's a thing that we're
going to we will have to look at but
that's been the like that's been that
way so I think we're fine for
now now we do need to figure out how to
set this I think that this m set was
actually correct then we'll just double
check on that
set yeah that looks
good all right
now we change this to
28 you see how our thing
I adjust puffer not. to modify ARG input
types to floats other Ms that have
discrete actions over yeah you got to
change it right um so Arc input types to
floats no what you should do for now is
you write them into a temporary buffer
right so instead of writing the actions
directly into the end you write them
into just like a float array and then
you copy them over and when you assign
them it'll get
one yeah this is unmasked actually
completely for
MK well we'll have to profile this to
see where this is coming out of
overhead we'll run it though see if this
makes a difference with the without the
masking if ites do make a difference
without the masking then it stands that
to reason that we could probably do
better by fully fixing the
uhoh oh wait yeah cuz the Mas are wrong
that's fine
yeah we'll try this at least give it a
Fighting
Chance can't mask the whole freaking
reward function
cool so this will now run and we'll see
if it matches we will keep it if not we
will not
hilarious it literally just goes I guess
I'm a bad guy now
huh you know I wonder how much is
getting messed up by the episode bounds
then
right probably a lot is getting messed
up by the episode
bounds
yeah this is definitely
broken I'm going to just rerun to make
sure I didn't break you know the other
uh unless I broke it somewhere else
completely
up I think this is still uh there's
still a gap
right oh yeah there's still a big
gap okay if I comment
this I'm want to
underperforming this thing's still way
underperforming
right oh hold on I'm
dumb hang on hang
on
big yeah I left this at
yeah I think the goal is just going to
be before dinner we make sure that this
works have this set
up and then
experiments yeah there you go totally
different story right
we'll give them like 20 M steps a piece
to match
curve be pretty quick
yeah that's a match with the
previous uh this previous curve pretty
much exactly great so now we do
this hold on whoops I mean this and this
yeah
not
TR this is just reward
block we make sure this matches and then
we test the fast
oh come on there's actually a little Gap
I'm not going to know if
I'll come
on so now there's no way for me to
know does it catch up it should be the
same
thing it's catching up I think it's
fine yeah it's caught up it'll the next
update it'll be sink and we'll be fine
under I mean I don't see how this could
possibly have been any
well I think it's got to be fine we'll
check this we'll go recheck the faster
one again
drive me nuts like checking identical
obser like identical code because of
noise
and just the
I'm pretty damn certain that this is the
same
no run one more time just to see the
seed
nuts we're not running the whole thing
this
what I don't know why there's so much
just garbage in the
feed like I want this to have to be AI
gap like I don't understand how there
could be a gap
yeah cuz these two match like very
closely and then this one was up
the
rewards zeroing the rewards if I like
somehow I didn't do
that I'll go double check that I would
be very concerned if that
mattered
shouldn't oh I see it I'm the [ __ ] okay
now I see it I'm a [ __ ]
there yeah and we can see that the
curves were already starting to differ
because I yeah I just screwed it up
that's fine
and then we'll try again with the fast
one just to double check but I think the
fast one probably will have a per
drop based on that result not zeroing
the uh the mask out
I mean actually that just tells you
right like I don't even have to run the
experiment it just tells you that there
is a perfect
hit so we make sure this is good and we
are set
yeah and they should nicely
track the black
curve it's nice when RL is consistent
and stable isn't
it yeah that's perfect okay so that's
what the issue was
um we did speed stuff up a little bit at
the very least so this was not a
complete
waste steps
perfect and these match we don't need to
we don't need to run these to like watch
variants for the next however
long this is
fine yeah it's just going to torture us
with the very
better to not even
bother
um
okay almost time for
dinner got a few more runs
here the runs are too expensive for some
reason I don't know how they're taking
that long actually come to think of it
definitely something screwy with the
cost
there but at least now we have a a good
reason for why you know the longer ones
might not do
better so I think we we are good for
now we don't really need that ablation
to
work um
yeah so I mean that's pretty well the
first thing I wanted to look at well
explained
uh I guess after this we can come back
and we can look at automatic parameter
sweeps
potentially I can cue something up just
real quick just as a quick
test breakouts a pretty quick
sweep at least isn't
it I think we should do pong
quick what I wanted to try
was this default scale
for auto scale but actually I don't even
have this implemented for everything
yet I don't even have this implemented
yet so we'll deal with that after I
think 1 hour in house
progress uh I mean we have the whole
thing nicely refactored we optimized
some stuff we cleaned it up we have
everything working as before so we're
pry in a pretty good spot here and we
have everything pushed to Dev so we're
in a pretty good spot for uh the next
batch of research that I need to
do oh and I came up with a new algorithm
idea as well so maybe we'll have a third
one but I'm just about to go to dinner
so I'm going to go do that uh and then
we will
see yeah we will see uh when I'm back
after dinner what we
do thanks folks and if you're interested
in following any of my stuff buffer.
star repo really helps us out join the
disc board if you're interested in that